all right we're back for another episode
of the worth it watches worth it show we
don't have a name yet we're workshopping
some things yes Adams behind the camera
he's gonna tell us what we're watching
today okay number ten now let's kick
this off handy Oh
number ten is the custom candy from
Japan yeah the one where we got Adams
face turned into a little stuff there it
is I love when we blur out stuff in the
beginning of videos because all the
comments go insane they're like we see
it in the thumbnail why are you blurting
it out here we blurred out because it's
funny and because it conveys a point
beyond just obscuring what the thing is
yes it's to titillate yearlings to uh
you know say that there's more to come
ah it was so hot in this room it was
like literally hot enough to keep the
candy in a molten State so I was just
pouring with sweat the whole time I did
you like several shirt changes because I
was operating the amra yeah and then we
want to do this interview I really like
that we get to cover stuff like this on
the show like how old unique is this
it's awesome
are we needed that part where you almost
lose a finger yeah yeah you were bad at
that you stretched it too thin and then
I did something very bad which was you
have to feed the ends into this machine
I was just trying to like guide it along
a little bit there you get a good shot
of my sweat I'm just oh my good
completely wet there oh my I still gets
me I just I was just like oh it needs a
little bit of help I was in control of
the situation
oh my look how close he is it is that it
only looks that way because of the
camera angle it is a very global problem
we still have like buckets of these
candy by the way I do
what are we get we gave them away at
VidCon that's right we hand them out
whenever we can 786 dollars is a lot of
money but this was for over 3,000 pieces
of candy yeah so that's about I think
it's like onee cents a piece yeah number
nine oh man yes this was one of the
coolest places I actually get a lot of
questions about how this tastes like in
my real day-to-day life people always
ask me how was that coffee I remember
you were obsessed with the motorcycles
this guy was very cool he has these
motorcycles in his cafe he I remember he
was talking about how we got this very
unique like I don't know how many
cylinders it has but it's like an
oversized engine maybe it's for the
Muench for he was talking about like how
fast he could get from Osaka to Tokyo
was it were like some distance that he
was commuting he was just like hauling
ass on the highway on his motorcycle
this was one of the funnest shoots
because we were actually like out in the
suburbs yes in this little neighborhood
where this little cafe exists where we
brought $900 in cash that's right yeah
who this place this guy did not have a
credit card machine that we could use we
were there very late at night yeah
very late so you're saying people ask
you all the time about the way it tastes
all the time they asked me was it really
worth it and I will say it was one of
the most interesting things I've ever
tasted I would not buy it again but it
was literally a chocolate coffee taser
in my mouth number eight we have a tie
we have a tie for six seven and eight
uh yes we're in Australia oh my gosh
yeah this was incredible that dog oh
this was maybe my favorite episode ever
to shoot also it was cold in Australia
yes summertime well knows they're winter
so they're winter our summer yeah so we
were not prepared for how cold it was
I found that very pleasant I was like
this is nice they some crisp weather you
know it's just like the fall shout out
to the Australian Tourism Board
we're really taking care of us like this
was an amazing experience they really
showed us Australia right this was a
sort of a difficult shooting situation
for us on the show you know we always
like to show as much as possible of your
process obviously wine takes you know
months to grow the grapes then it's
harvesting then it's bottling and aging
and so forth for many many years yeah so
like they didn't have anything growing
at that time and so we're shooting like
going down into his old family cellar
you know walking around with his dog all
that kind of good stuff man that was a
good wine though I have a really cool
hand-drawn text here who did that so
yeah so this is a great example of how
you know other people help out on our
show we had somebody in our art
department here at BuzzFeed actually
hand draw that text on-screen yeah
it was somebody named Katherine Davis
bagel oh okay hey hey this is before I
moved in New York this is making me
realize that I own one jacket and I own
a thousand yeah so here we are trying
the thousand dollar bagel this one's
very unique because it was not for the
business purposes of this restaurant but
instead it was for a charitable cause
right so they were basically trying to
like make a really expensive food item
so that they could give the money to
this soup kitchen I mean here's the
thing is the bagel itself $1,000
no but do you ever eat a bagel without
toppings on it no so does another bagel
is gonna be a bagel that has some
expensive toppings on it I think that
toppings on them really just plain bread
yeah that is crazy I am Airport I'm at
the bucks
I need something just to like get my
stuff
I started I'll just throw a bagel in my
mouth you are Michael Scott ice cream oh
so in New York this is a very early
episode yes season two so this
restaurant is actually not this guy he
there's a lot of really crazy expensive
things yeah just loves to find expensive
ingredients and see how he can place
them on accessible foods yeah there's a
come on
there's a grilled cheese we actually
then went back to do the burger for
Rachael Ray's talk show yes that was
really fun since they're like Rachael
Ray delightful in person there's a
little behind-the-scenes for you
I mean look is it crazy that this guy
made this thousand dollar sundae yeah
but look at that thing if he hadn't done
it you'd never see anything like that
ever existing in the world yes season
one Stephen almost a flattop I remember
it was really only you chose these
flavors for the cake okay oh oh whoa
whoa whoa can we clear this up I did not
choose the flavors for this cake who did
he did okay yes it's true I brought you
here to give you this awesome cake but
all the creative direction on the cake
we left up to Bottega to figure out and
they wanted to really create something
that was fanciful you know Jess stick
I'm a fool it tasted really good I'm not
gonna deny that it was it tastes like
fondant yeah a lot of fondant I thought
that I mean look you got all those
flavor options there and uh yeah okay
this is I didn't get to go to this
consultation you did film it though no I
did not yeah you were there in the room
was I yeah you were there I have no
recollection of that you definitely were
there Wow
but this was cool I mean he really spent
a lot of time designing this yeah and
that shot the time-lapse shot yeah
yeah that really ties it together I mean
so this was actually one of our longest
food filming periods for the show I
think we took like three days to go back
at different stages of the process it
was also quite the experience
this is what me and Adam used to edit of
these videos and I remember he spent so
much time building the b-roll sequence
for this and it's so satisfiying like oh
you guys don't realize how much time you
know is spent behind the camera or
behind the edits putting these together
but that I feel like the time-lapse
shots really convey like just how much
effort goes into it you know we use a
lot of slow-motion on the show but the
time-lapse really shows you like wow
this guy has to sit there and actually
do that but come on it is a me
yeah I mean that like if you're buying a
cake for a special occasion what is
gonna make it really memorable it's
gonna be something like this like super
unique shape number four bento box I
love a box we go from the present shaped
cake to the present looking box of food
this pressed yeah the pressed sushi was
actually my favorite thing I ate on this
whole no way filming it was really up
there I thought it was super unique I
thought it tasted amazing I loved it a
lot was absurd but the best 1593 dollars
okay look at that box yeah it's a hand
carved you get to keep the box that is
awesome I would love to take that home
and put some stuff in it so the way that
we actually save a little bit of budge
on this shoot is we did not pay for the
box right the in green side but we did
feature the box right we got the
experience of opening it up and yeah we
pay for the food yeah we paid for the
food number three speaking of Japanese
was the greatest experience of filming
this show oh my goodness okay we were
hot and tired in this cab filming the
intro and it was like you know you're
walking around all day you finally get
into an air-conditioned cab where they
have this nice drape on the seats and
you're just like this is nice so we're
very low
energy and Adam was like how are we
going to make the beginning of this
video good and exciting and engaging and
so he created this monstrosity of a
montage at the beginning yes that is now
the standard for how we do the one-stop
APIs look at that
lots of zooming
[Music]
that music track which is now infamous
when we bought this grapes by the way
you know the ladies at the cash register
started laughing but they did not
realize we're actually going to buy the
grapes
yeah they for them they thought we were
just like filming a pretend scene they
were like oh yeah come over here we'll
wrap it up very nice and then we whipped
out the card and they were like oh
you're buying it oh my thank you
very fun where is the actual evidence
that we pay for the food on this show
well I am still just every time I think
about the actual fact that that bunch of
grapes cost $2,000 it's it's wild and we
ate it in an afternoon
so we ain't like maybe two grapes each
on that roof and then we brought the
whole package back to the BuzzFeed Japan
office and let everybody who works there
eat a grape as well we were just walking
around with this box and they were like
wait I can actually eat this right now
another one of those down though number
two oh yeah so this was a big debate
about whether we really wanted to show
this 2,000 dollar pizza on the on the
episode so we had already made the first
worth of video we made together was
pizza and Los Angeles then we were like
oh we should do pizza again in New York
New York has a ton of great pizza
restaurants mm-hmm and we were debating
what the high end should be and then we
were like should we do a pizza that's
like $150 or should we do this pizza
that's two thousand dollars right and so
this is so cool it's that classic pizza
shop a spice shaker you know that
usually has parmesan or red pepper
flakes but it's filled with gold flakes
I know and he's shaking it off it's
insane I know what it is
secret menu secret mini souffle I
thought it's really funny that this guy
had two watches on he's got an Apple
watch and then also some like probably
really nice I forgot about that you know
it's kind of standard-looking watch
murder also when the guy was running to
like the ramen shop I was around you yes
I think that's a thing you know you have
like a digital watch for timing and then
like a Fitbit or like something else in
a different style yeah this is the only
time I've ever seen somebody do that in
real life yeah yeah I never was that the
first time yeah go back I actually did
not know oh my gosh because you're not
very observant Steve no it's because
we're watching it on it like a 70-inch
TV right now Wow
I remember this was a very difficult
shoot to block out when each shot was
gonna take place because there's so many
steps he smokes it then it's under the
glass and it's like okay how are we
going to get the shot of him revealing
the smoke and then igniting the Hennessy
and then pouring it it seems pretty
straightforward but to actually capture
each of those in satisfying detail yeah
and then because we can only order one
$25 or play yeah be prepared to sit down
and like start the taste test while it's
still hot and good it's it's very
difficult okay so that's been an episode
of worth it watches worth it slash worth
it post-mortem let us know what you
think about this this is a new series
that we're trying while we have other
full worth it episodes in production
those are coming along in the future
mm-hmm but that was that
[Music]